what if you could predict the future
with a photograph it'd be pretty cool
right
oh my god dude i look like i'm like a
homeless guy there's a brand new
artificial intelligence algorithm that
came out that can let us try doing just
that so we're going to put it to the
test it's called style clip you give it
a picture of a human face and you can
type in literally anything and have it
alter that face to match that
you want a beard you want something like
when you're bald once you see what you
look like if you're an alien on another
planet it can do all these things so
we're going to feed this pictures of
ourselves as children we're going to
have the computer predict what we would
look like as adults using these pictures
we're going to compare it to the real
thing and see how close it gets and not
just that we have some other wacky fun
and games with this too because like i
said you can type in anything so come
join us as we explore the most cutting
edge of computer technology
so i want to show you how this crazy ai
works and to do this we could do sam
face you could do my face i tried to
photo scan my face the other day and
it's totally screwed up because of the
beard
i don't feel like we should do your face
first first things first i have to take
this picture and like encode it into the
ai space so in order for this ai to
change your face the computer is like it
looks at you and then closes its eyes
and tries to use its memory to go all
right what did i just see so it's not
gonna be perfect because it has to
basically make up my face from its
collage of learned faces but it's close
enough for the sake of now manipulating
it i wanted to give me a celebrity tom
cruise face all right well first has to
describe the face that we're already
seeing which is just a face and then i
have to go to target tom cruise face and
then literally from there i hit go
okay it's like eric lyndon's version of
me ai is so stupid
like it's the most advanced thing in the
world and then it all boils down to two
text boxes and then like decades of
human ingenuity and research and
development go into the image you see
right there and then there's two sliders
what are the sliders doing the beta is
basically the amount of parameters you
can change think of it like the number
of character sliders in skyrim and then
alpha is how extreme it will make those
changes so if you want to maintain like
the likeness of somebody you don't want
to change too many sliders otherwise
everything will change max it out
crank it all the way
gross
[Laughter]
man i'm gonna capture photo dude take
your hat off
what's your ethnicity where are you from
greek all right encoding
okay it actually matt
a pretty solid job the computer's
imagination of matt is pretty accurate
it's actually really close it kind of
greeks you up a little bit already it
did it got me a little tanner yeah so we
could see what matt looks like when he's
even more greek i want to see tzatziki
sauce coming out of your ears i would
love it oh yeah yeah yeah here we go my
eyebrows are starting to connect slowly
but surely
yeah yeah this is like touchy ground but
i'm gonna do it anyways because human
faces come in a lot of different sizes
shapes and colors so for example let's
do korean oh wow wow oh wow dude that's
nuts because it actually still looks
like yeah yeah the eyebrows are
completely the same the facial hair
everything else hey jordan don't see
what your brother would look like if you
had a brother okay here we go i'm gonna
see what jordan looked like if she was a
man
my brother looks better than me
face with 80s hair
now is it going to interpret it as the
decade or the age
[Music]
for me what gets me really excited about
ai is when we have stuff that's
completely generated by the ai and
doesn't really require as much of that
underlying
image to base itself off of deep fakes
are really cool because you can get a
really lifelike version of someone's
identity onto someone else my only issue
with it is that you still need that
foundational actor to drive the
performance but it's cooler when you can
create a face out of nothing so to speak
so we're doing all these like you know
image manipulations for the face but in
order to test this we need to be testing
age so i want everybody here to give me
pictures of themselves as kids but we're
gonna see if this ai can accurately
predict what you would look like is that
what you would actually look like yeah
let's find out
so let's start with me
as a little wee toddler well not really
taller like three four years old so i
have to describe what the original
picture is i've described the
destination let's try
old face let's just see what happens
it takes the brow it just comes right
scrunches it so now to ask myself do i
want to limit what's happening here
because it's kind of keeping the face
shape right and it's kind of keeping the
curly blonde hair so i kind of want to
open it up to affect more sliders so
let's try that
whoa ooh gross freddy krueger face
freddy krueger yeah so let's try nick
laurent here behind the camera let's
just do the classic child face a skinny
adult male face
that's actually pretty good that's
pretty good the best part of this is it
keeps the child's hair cut like the
super weird frankenstein haircuts that
we all had when we were kids it keeps
that on our male counterparts sam which
picture would you like me to work with
this one with trying a bowl of cereal
and like just chilling like hey what's
that or the one on the boat that was the
first boat i stole
[Laughter]
let's do the chilling and then the boat
one will be the grand reveal sam it's
pretty close it's really definitely not
going to age correctly because it's not
quite there
[Laughter]
i look like a freaking alaskan dude it's
time for griffin to see his future
here's old man griffin
oh
that's accurate yeah comparison of his
father to old man griffin it's actually
not that far off you're not adopted
that's so uncanny dude i'm starting to
identify a problem here and that is if
you don't know your destination you
don't know if this is pushing you in the
right direction so there's a bit of the
question here can i dial in can i get it
to look like me now it's for a child
face and let's try adult male face with
beard
okay we're getting there i might have to
lose the beard for now but we'll see oh
i'm looking like dane yeah once i start
pushing that beard it starts losing the
face shape because it's like there's
just not enough data what do you think
would this one work
yeah that would work it's not gonna look
like you don't work wow that's actually
pretty i mean i look like poor man's
neil patrick harris hey hey elise is
better than michael sarah for once
oh yeah oh my god there's michael so
rather than trying to dial in all the
settings at once let's do this i'm going
to snip tool this version of nick here
i'm going to get the beard on nick by
running it through this again oh
no
no if the ears are getting like more and
more
[Music]
[Applause]
that's it
it's accurate science has predicted what
ren would look like if you did math for
10 years this is too much power man can
you just strike fishermen fishermen all
right i'll turn up the fisherman values
yeah
i knew it i knew it if you guys want any
other help getting these faces a little
more accurate
next thing most important we have uh
griffin
[Music]
don't worry about it you can save those
ones right there there's four good ones
i'll go get a dustpan
i think we were all wondering what's
going to look like is ball we're just
talking about
phil collins
i gave you an earring
he just knew reptile face here we go
he's like one of those little thumb
people shrimp
skinny shrimp skinny shrimp shrimp
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so we're discovering that we need to
write skinny if we're working with baby
faces because there's a lot of baby
found them so skinny adult male face
with beard okay
it's actually not that bad the eyes
relatively close my brow isn't quite
that low so we're kind of running into
probably a little bit of a data set
thing here on top of just the face not
quite being minus start with oh can you
do meth can you do oh we gotta do
matching yeah first we gotta do math
next
there it is
oh
no that's beautiful oh hello ladies
whoever this boy is here when they grow
up this is a pretty solid interpretation
of what direction they could go in is it
me
not really no
so there's no sponsor on today's video
because we've got a website
corridordigital.com we got lots of great
content here if you've been wanting to
get those vlogs back well guess what
they're on the website right now the
crew cuts show on the website basically
it's the vlogs they come out at least
twice a week look at all of these crew
cut videos this is just the crew cuts
the website also has all the videos that
go on to all of our youtube channels
they go out early and they contain no
ads we also have a bunch of original
shows that you can green light yourself
check it out we got a pretty cool system
here one of our most recent shows from
the green light feature would be
functional filmmaking it's basically a
master class covering all types of
filmmaking for online content we wrote
it we made it we produced it it's for
you
we also have our dnd campaign called son
of a dungeon and that was pretty sweet
and we're actually doing something
really cool that i haven't really seen
anyone else try we basically 3d scanned
the entire game set and we're going to
be putting ourselves into the game set
to get some live-action virtual
production of the funniest and coolest
bits from the game this is actually kind
of snowballed into one of the biggest
visual effects projects we've ever done
so stay tuned for that in a couple
months i'm excited so yeah check it out
it's only four bucks a month if you're
interested it's actually a really great
way to directly support us so if you
like our content consider it if not no
worries i'll see you next time on the
youtube vids
so we've gone through we've aged up a
bunch of other crew members and we're
gonna show them the results here and see
what they think i want to see if you
guys can guess who is in each picture
you can guess who that adult is or who
that child was congratulations you are
proving that ai is superior to human
beings all right here we go i'm gonna
pull the first picture you guys guess
who it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
i didn't alter the haircut so everybody
has like the haircuts they had in third
grade in these pictures yeah you still
got the baby teeth
baby
next up
[Music]
dude your eyes are doing this we can
tell it's steamed but it definitely does
not quite look like dean it kind of
makes sense though because dean's child
photo did not really look like dean in
the first place he looked like a
different person as a kid
look at those freaking eyebrows though
they gave me like extra that's matt and
mr beans
the picture i used was for like matt
when he was maybe like 10. so it was
pretty easy just to bump it up a little
bit
that's me with baby teeth also you look
like you're from hobbiton
do you have a meth folder oh here you
guys also see math nico
looks like the guy from it's always
sunny oh yeah
[Laughter]
that's ren for sure 100 with a little
bit of linus
more than even the most tricked out
all right next
[Music]
sam's picture was a really poorly
smiling kid and so apparently the key
word rugged needed to be added to start
pushing it more towards like an adult
version of sound by the way there's a
finger or something
that's disgusting 90s fully sam
[Laughter]
oh my god
a nick right there it's pretty close
we're trying to figure out this looks
exactly like some actor a lot of these
faces are from celebrities basically
there's hints of actors in all of our
faces right now
[Music]
look at all the little shrimp in the
background
thanks for looking to everybody
[Applause]
i feel like the aging is relatively
accurate is it as good as an artist's
interpretation probably not but
everybody could tell who the photos
belong to and for what it's worth i was
able to do these in like five minutes
each versus like an artist having to go
in and spend like a day doing it the
frontier of artificial intelligence
machine learning is going to change our
lives and i'm trying to explore it in
the world of film and visual effects and
art here in corridor so if you want to
see more of this cool stuff consider
subscribing because every once in a
while you might see a little cutting
edge never before seen effect happening
here once in a while through ai